♪ [music] ♪
So let's review where we are in this
process. In coming up with the discounted
cash flow valuation of a company
we've talked about estimating cash flows
and discount rates, we then moved on to
growth, and then we closed off by looking
at terminal value. We're almost there,
right? You discount the cash flows back
add to your cost of capital,
you should come up with a value.
But what is that value? So let's
talk about what you get as your
present value when you discount
cash flows back at a discount rate.
It depends on what the cash flows
were and what discount rate you used.
If you discounted dividends at the cost
of equity, what you get as a present value
is the value of equity.  So
in the dividend discount model,
you're done. If you'd estimated free
cash flow as equity, potential dividends,
and discounted them back at the cost
of equity, what you get is the value
of equity but to the extent that you have
equity options outstanding that managers
might have been granted options to get to
a value per share. Now there's some work
to do. But if you discounted free cash
flows the firm at the cost of capital,
your work, unfortunately, is just
beginning because here's what
you've estimated. By discounting the free
cash for the firm at the cost of capital,
you valued the operating assets
of the company. Let me explain why.
The free cash flow to the firm is
based on operating income, right?
So you've estimated the value of any
assets whose earnings are part
of operating income. Put differently,
you haven't valued any of those assets
whose earnings are not part of operating
income. I don't mean to sound mysterious,
but if you value a company like Apple,
you know what you haven't valued yet?
You haven't valued the cash that the
company has. If you have companies that
have cross-holdings in other companies,
you haven't valued those cross-holdings
yet. So you've got to add the cash,
you have to add the cross-holdings.
In some cases, there might be other
assets you might add on to this value,
assets that haven't been
utilized that are vacant assets.
That gives you the value of the
firm. To get to the value of equity,
you need to subtract out the
value of debt. But that's not all.
To the extent that you granted equity
options or restricted stock to managers
in your company, that reduces your
value of equity in common stock.
You got to subtract out at least
the value of the equity options,
and what you're left with is the value
of the equity in the common stock.
So let's talk about each of the items that
you have to deal with after you value the
cash flows to get to the value of
equity per share. Let's start with cash.
The normal rule with cash is, don't
mess with it. If you have a company
with $100 million in cash, just
add the $100 million and move on,
and that's what we tend to do
in discounted cash flow valuations.
But let me ask you a provocative question.
Are there conditions where you see a
company with $100 million in cash where
you might actually treat the $100 million
as worth less than $100 million, if so,
why? Or more than $100 million,
if so, why? To illustrate why this might
happen, let me give you three companies
that look exactly the same in terms
of enterprise value and cash. In fact,
all three companies have $100
million in cash on their balance sheet.
But here's how they're different.
Company A has a history of earning a
return on capital roughly equal to its
cost of capital, and is a developed
market company. Company B is a
company with a history of taking bad
projects, earning a return in capital
of 5% when its cost to capital is 10%,
also developed market company.
Company C has a history of taking
good projects, earning well above its cost
to capital, about 10% more than its cost
to capital, and it's an emerging market
company. I'm going to argue that in one
of these three companies cash is going
to be a neutral asset. What do I mean
by a neutral asset? $100 million
in cash is going to be valued at roughly
$100 million. In one of these three
companies, cash might be discounted
in the hands of the company,
and I'd like you to start thinking
about which one. And one of these three
companies, cash might actually have a
premium attached to it. Think about it.
I would argue that in Company A,
cash is going to be a neutral asset.
Why? Because this company has a history
of being a blah company.
What's a blah company?
A blah company is one that earns
roughly its cost of capital. It does no
good, it does no damage. In Company B,
I'm going to argue that cash might have a
discount attached to it. Why? Not
because it's cash and earns a low rate
of return but because you're afraid of
what the company might do with the cash.
This company has a history of taking bad
projects. You're afraid they will use the
cash to take more bad projects.
There will be a stupidity discount you
attach to the cash. For the third company,
you might actually attach a premium
to the cash, and here is why. Not
only does it have a history of taking
good projects, but it's an emerging
market, in this case, Argentina.
A market where, in the last 15 years,
there have been at least four scenarios or
four time periods where capital markets
have shut down, both equity and debt
markets. Having cash in a market like
that one could be a strategic weapon that
adds value to the company. Adds value
why? Because this cash can be used not
only to allow the company to survive
a period where capital markets shut
down, but be used to buy assets from other
companies that are desperate for the cash.
Put differently, cash might sometimes
have a premium or discount attached to it.
In fact, there is some evidence
that markets actually do this.
This is actually from a study that looked
at how much a dollar in cash is valued
in the hands of a U.S. company.
And here's what it found. On average,
a dollar in cash is valued at about a
dollar, which is what we tend to do
in discounted cash flow valuations.
But if you look at mature companies,
slow growth companies with negative
excess returns, companies like company B,
here's what you find.
A dollar in cash is valued
at about 69 cents. That's a 31%
discount. And if you focus on young
growth companies, especially smaller
companies that face capital constraints,
companies like Company C, a
dollar in cash is valued at $1.22.
So if you're adding on the cash
balance to get your value for your firm,
keep doing what you're doing. But
in some cases, when you find your
company to be undervalued,
step back and think about why that
might be. It just might be that investors
don't trust the company with the cash that
it has on its hands. Let's
talk about cross-holdings.
Cross-holdings are difficult to value
because the accounting for cross-holdings
is all over the place. In fact,
generically, there are three ways a
cross holding can be accounted
for. It can be treated as a minority
passive investment, in which case,
here's what you're going to see.
In the income statement, you're
going to see the dividends you
receive from that cross-holdings.
In the balance sheet,
you're going to see what you originally
invested to get that cross-holding.
Already, you can see a disconnect opening
up between what you see on the income
statement and the balance sheet
and the value of a cross-holding,
especially if you invest in a company
that's become a very valuable
successful company. The second scenario
for accounting is, if you own 15%,
20% of a company and you're treated
as having some control of that company.
In that case, the accounting is treated
as a minority active investment.
What happens then? In the income
statement, you have to show 15% or 20%,
depending on the percentage you own of the
net income or net loss of that subsidiary.
So not dividends, but net income
or net loss, that's a little better.
And on the balance sheet, you
have to show what you originally
invested plus some minus retained
earning sets. So it's an updated book
value, a little better than minority
passive investments. But if you own
40%, 45%, 50%, or 55% of a company,
you might be viewed as effectively
controlling the company. When you
do that, accountants consolidate.
What does that mean?
In your income statement,
you record a 100% of the revenues
in the operating income of the subsidiary.
In the balance sheet, you have
to record a 100% of the assets
and the debt of the subsidiary.
But you own only 60%, right?
So here's what accountants do
to bring your financial statements back
into balance. They take the 40% that
does not belong to you and show it
as a liability. It's called a
noncontrolling interest on a
minority interest. Why am I going
on and on about the accounting
for cross-holdings? Because if you
don't understand how cross-holdings are
accounted for, you really cannot value
them. So let me at least set up how you
would value cross-holdings in a
perfect world. If you gave me a company
with cross-holdings in a perfect
world, here's what I would do.
I would value the parent company standing
alone, and then I take each cross holding,
minority or majority, and value
that subsidiary standing alone
as well. Then to value of the parent
company with the cross-holdings,
I take the value of the parent company
plus the percentage of each subsidiary
that belongs to that company. That
is the best way to value a company
with cross-holdings, but
already you can see the barriers
you're going to face in doing this.
To do this, you'll need full financial
statements for the parent company
as well as full financial statements
for each and every subsidiary. And
if you can get that, you can do it right.
You can value it as the sum of the parts
of the company. I'm not sure whether your
company has cross-holdings,
but it definitely will have cash.
So here's the first thing I'd like you
to do. If you've done the discounted cash
flow valuation for your company,
and you've used a free cash flow to the
firm and a cost to capital to get there,
add on the cash for the moment.
Don't worry about discounting it or
premiuming it, just add on the cash.
We'll come back and talk about what
to do if you don't trust the company
later. Then check for cross-holdings.
You will find the vestiges
of cross-holdings on your balance sheet.
Why vestiges? Because the numbers you see
on the balance sheet will not be the
numbers that reflect the values
of those cross-holdings. Depending
on how the cross-holdings are
accounted for, you have
a lot more work to do.
♪ [music] ♪